hi everyone and welcome to a another a
pack Android developer office hours so
this is the type of show where you
basically join on and ask us android
development questions what we do is we
post the moderator link before ahead of
time so that you can post your your
questions ahead of time as well and once
you do so then we come online and we
answer them the other thing is that you
can actually ask your questions live on
the stream as well so please do join us
and we can answer your your Android
development related questions so let me
just introduce my colleague tony chen
hello Tony's joining us from Hong Kong
as usual and my name is Ankur Kotwal and
I'm joining you from Sydney Australia so
Tony and I are in the Android developer
relations team and here to answer your
questions we have some people who are
joining in terms of the number of
viewers on the stream so so welcome to
everyone following there we have a
number of questions that have been
submitted but I made a mistake this week
and that i made the moderator expire a
little bit early so people weren't able
to get their questions in so if you're
if you're tuning in now or you haven't
asked asked your questions yet now's a
good time to do so what we'll do is
we'll start off by answering questions
during that are already posted and we
will do a refresh the thread and just
see if there's any other questions that
have been asked in the meanwhile so
let's get started we're on the moderator
link I'll read out the question and then
we can answer them first question is
it's from Owen Cassidy in Sydney
Australia actually Tony would you like
to read this one out and answer it sure
um so the question was I have been
trying to use to be the new
content view for notification in jelly
bean is there a way to make my big
content view a normal know the
notification with an extension below it
I keep ending up with it replacing the
entire modification with my we might
remove it so um for the so which
notification is something new and so my
understanding with your from your
passion is your your existing content
view which is the remote various
services is is replaced by the content
be right arm I think in terms of in
terms when when we use the big content
view for notification is really
switching between the normal content
view and the big content view if you
expand the view will be replaced by the
content view so in seems like you want
to preserve the existing content in when
you show the normal are one unit of view
in that case like i was saying maybe you
have to you use the same the the one you
are you i actually adding into your big
content view if that's what you want so
if it will be send us your question feel
free to add a asum kind of clarification
in in the stream in the G+ stream so
great thanks 20 yep all right so formula
from Hong Kong has a question for us
would you give us a suggestion or when
to use the Google Maps Android API web
views showing a page using the Google
Maps JavaScript API v3 or using intense
to call with the URL of GT 0 colon map
activity does not support fragments
webview is slow
and intent calls have limited function
so that's a really good question from
basically there are there are a number
of ways that you can integrate and use
maps in your own app and you know the
three that you mentioned the Maps API
using a web view and using the the
JavaScript API and the intense are a
good summary of the ways you can
interact with them and you also went on
to point out that that the current map
view on on android doesn't actually it
doesn't work very well with fragments
you have to use something that's called
a map activity and with the map activity
you can you can only have one app
process and it's part of your activity
itself I'm sorry just before i continue
hi Andrew how are you hi good thanks hey
will I'll just finish answering this map
question and then if you've got some
questions we'll ask you live in the
meantime do you mind if you could just
meet your mind thanks a lot alright so
back to the question right now map
activity does have a few limitation then
we've had better feedback a lot of
feedback from developers that says hey
we'd like to be addressed so you don't
have a solution for the moment what you
can do in the meanwhile pretty much use
our map activities or use web views let
me tell you where they differ so the
Google Maps Android API that you're
referring to is what is what I mean when
I say map activity and yes it's not a
it's got a somewhat limited feature set
you know the JavaScript API has has
added a whole bunch of new capabilities
that are not yet available are in the
map activity so it depends really what
you want to do with your app if your app
is the type of app that is able to work
well with a map activity i would say use
that because it's trended natively it
gives you the most speed and performance
in your app
if you're looking to do some of the more
advanced things with it with a map you
will notice that the JavaScript API v3
actually has a lot of capabilities in
there so you know if you need those
advanced capabilities or the newer
capabilities use the web view and
finally if you're if you're just using
in your in your app you're just using a
naps to sort of redirect users to a
particular business or a particular
location what you can do is finally you
can use the oil in it and it will take
me there so it really is it's a little
bit of a trade-off at the moment you're
absolutely right we don't we don't have
you know fragment support in there yet
and we don't have some of the newer
capabilities it's something that we we
do give feedback to the engineering team
so it's good to hear that people are
doing it it's something that we will
look to prioritize as best we can so
unfortunately not a single answer that
says hey this is what you should always
do have a look at what your needs are
and use the right API accordingly so
thanks for so we have a couple of people
that have joined us Andrew was the first
one that joined us so Andrew did you
have any questions for us actually your
mutant still muted the facial
expressions are priceless stir well
until until Andrew works out his
microphone will let's let's shift to
someone else we have emre on the line
Azure hi emre well I can't hear Emery
that turn you over to here are just just
now I'm just following though okay all
right so all right well that's fine
Andrews you might microphone up yet no
um if you give us a thumbs up if you've
got a question or you're just tuning in
just a sort of being passive thumbs down
all right no problems
we have Kyle joining us as well and he's
just dropped out so what we might do is
in the meanwhile take another question
from moderator thread Tony do you want
to go grab this one from academia from
Taiwan yeah sure so the question was I
saw Android developer share circles for
Android development like Android
developers Paris android usergroup etc
is there any circle form from a pact
area anyway place I can find out this
information um I guess the answer to
this question is really arm because all
the circles are created by these
particular groups and it's really open
to all this community of I think the
best way to find out whether there's a
there's an existing group for the area
is to reach out to these music groups
and see what they have created one and
if not you may want to encourage them to
play one arm probably that's the best
way to do to find out the information
yeah I might just add that a lot of
these google developer communities so
typically we have to track types of two
names that are given to these
communities one is a google developer
group which is GD g and often they they
cover more than just android so we have
a you know google has a number of
technologies and those communities are
interested in all of them yeah by the
way it was it was originally called G
Tugg tub so a lot of developers may may
may not get used to the new branding so
right yeah google so that was Google
technology user group that was the old
brand it used to be called G toggle
google technology as a group recently
been changed to Google developer groups
GD geez so have a look to see if there
are any in your area you according to
you post you from Taiwan so there could
be some communities there the other type
of community that you find they tend to
call themselves Android user groups or
Android developer groups and they also
exist enough they typically are kind of
like a subset of the
tons of the GD G's in that they they
specialize purely on Android so these
are like-minded people that are really
interested in Android development and so
what I would suggest is how to do a
search on Google Plus because i often
many of these communities have google+
pages and you know failing that do it do
a search on google itself i know that
the communities in in sydney and in
melbourne used meetup com to organize
their events so again your local
community may use a site like meet up or
something else to do so i'll just to add
to that not sure where which region are
you from in part from Taiwan but
definitely there are two very active or
GDG ones in Taipei and other one is in
culture yeah great alright thanks Tony
all right we have a another question
from Owen Cassidy in Sydney is there a
way to harness the two finger gesture to
expand notifications in other areas for
example to expand a relative layout to
reveal more information so the two
finger gesture notification is is
something that we added as part of the
rich notification feature in jellybean
and basically what it does is that
you're kind of on your device that
allows you to get a notification use two
fingers you sort of swipe down and it
expands that notification or you can use
two fingers to swipe off to shrink that
notification and that's something that
we've added especially for notifications
in relative layouts that behavior is not
the default behavior you can of course
capture those touch events and react to
them but it is code that you will have
to build yourself it is certainly not
something that's provided out of the box
so yeah I mean it sounds like that that
could be a usage pattern that might
become more popular but you'll need to
build it yourself all right we
have a another question from what we
from someone called nail I apologize if
I've mispronounced your name from San
Jose can google cloud messaging API be
used with google TV much like google
music but for media or personal content
so I'm a little bit unclear about this
this particular question to any of you
do you understand what what the person
is asking um not really yeah so Mike my
guess is like is mystic it's jeez or
Google Cloud messaging can be used for
our TV devices maybe it's right now most
most of most of the use case i heard is
mainly for mobile our mobile phones so
i'm really not sure yeah I if it's if
it's purely about Google Cloud messaging
for to use on google TV i think at the
moment that's not there it may be coming
in the future but yet it's tony said
typically not phones and tablets you
know devices that are on on standby or
have some ongoing connectivity so yeah
all right well we didn't actually have
that many questions this week
unfortunately the arm so any code areas
there's actually one more question in
the in the chat window Akash a casual
mommy asks a question why is creating an
NFC topples which widget not allow an
ICS jelly bean ah so the answer is I
would probably say I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I think it would
probably have to do something around
security it's something that uses would
probably want to have the ability to
turn on and off without apps doing it
for you that would be my my educated
guess Tony what about what about yeah I
I haven't
I haven't look at the API lately but is
it a cache is it because there's no api
calls available for enable/disable that
yeah there are no api's okay so we just
basically haven't exposed it that could
be for a number of reasons we haven't
got to it or where you know we want to
make sure it's secure that sort of thing
so um yeah well I mean usually when
there's no api's around it's it's
sometimes for a good reason sometimes
because we haven't got to it yet so I
don't know the definitive answer but um
yeah that's the state of it at the
moment do you think we can expect it we
get these sorts of questions all the
time when can we expect that are you
guys going to do this or that and in
general we can't talk about what we're
what we're going to do in the future
because you know these things can change
and if we if we commit to something then
it could you know and we end up changing
our how approach it makes us look silly
so I can't really say whether you can
expect it on on all right we had her
Rosa join on the Hangout Rosa if you
have you any questions for us okay we
can't hear Rosa Rosa if you if you do
have questions for us please just let
them let us know in the chat mr does
have a question he's posted it on the
chat I have one question if it's related
he's talking about UK courts and Apple I
mean if it's something outside of
development it's something we can't talk
about and certainly anything that's
related related to legal side of things
you know neither tomo nia or i are a
lawyer's so we wouldn't be able to give
you any you know reasonable answer
anyway we just be making it up so we'd
prefer not to and we do have another
question on the moderator however so
tourney do you want to grab it let me
take a look
so are there any plans to incorporate
access to google now cards either
third-party apps pulling data from them
and making their own cards available
ideally there will be an approval
process to prevent apps on spending arm
so I think right now Google now cards
are we don't we don't have an API for
that at the moment so as anchor
mentioned before like we don't we don't
pms like a road map so i guess this
really like stay tuned and and we heard
a lot of feedback from developer they
would meet like together hands on
accessing like having some sort api for
google mail carts and we definitely take
that as I feedback thanks yeah seems
like Tony we need to invest in a time
machine it'd be great to be able to
answer some of these questions about
what's going to happen in the future
anyways uh so if there are let me check
the the thread see whether there are any
other questions certainly now is the
time to ask any questions um but it
doesn't look like we have anything at
the moment so what we're going to do is
something that we haven't we haven't
done on this hangout before we've got
something special for you that Tony's
being been working on we've we've done a
developer interview with a with a
prominent developer in Hong Kong called
an America and Tony do you want to just
enjoy it with we're going to then show
the video yeah sure so I I spent a
morning with animal car a couple did
their CTO and intact meet over there are
they talk about how they do testing and
also like of showing some of their
games are and devices they use for
testing and it's really cool and by the
way we we love to get more interviews
with all you oh you guys are developers
and if you're interested and if and if
you are in one of our region's I if
you're in Hong Kong in Sydney we can
even like think of explore ideas like
well having a bit more interview in the
future if if if we have all the other or
the other equipments so so let's take a
look at the the video ankle are you
playing that yeah I will um just let me
get it set up so we're going to use the
the the YouTube app that's that's there
on on the Hangout and give us give us a
second
it looks like it doesn't want to play
that's that's uh interesting honey could
you could you try firing it up sure let
me try I'm sure the people in the stream
aren't going to believe us but we tested
it before hand and it worked okay yeah
Moore's Law is uh is definitely coming
in let me try all right so MRIs in the
meanwhile asking a question what about
devices are they related to ask I'm not
sure what the actual question is amorous
oh maybe if you just ask us the question
we can we can let you know if if it's
something that we have an answer for
I have to I have to link loader okay
just before before we start that lets em
adjusted the Nexus 7 is not available in
europe so i'm guessing you want to know
about availability it's just give us a
yes or no yep he wants to know about
availability that's actually something
we don't even have the Institute that's
you know we because we've had to develop
a relation we were very focused on on
the api's and the platform when it comes
to the consumer side of things you know
you guys are often are more aware of
what's happening than that then we can
be at times so sorry we don't we don't
actually know um alright Tony you want
to go by the way by the way that the
video is is flesh out of the studio so
we're going to be upload the video to
another more permanent account so don't
don't share this one we will be share
this in an hour plus android developer
plus h later so just such watch this one
for now all right take it away
these awkward pauses is it playing on
your end attorney because we don't we
don't see it it's actually playing
already so um the knee that's a shame
because it was working really well
beforehand I works for you so I cash are
you seeing the video ok so let me well
training what I think we'll do because I
certainly can't see it on my side
enamorada isn't able to see it let's
post the link separately i will upload
it to the to the right account and
posted separately we had hoped that we
would do it during the Hangout so that
we could have shown you guys the video
and then had some follow-up questions so
what we might do is just postpone it
these technical difficulties are
unfortunate that they happen from time
to time so yeah apologies for that we'll
we'll get to it oh am I can see Emma can
see that now too so but yes well I
separately in doubt let's let's sort it
out and see what happens ah so akash & M
rod do you guys have any follow-up
questions in the meanwhile hey anchor
you saw that actually cool Emmerich an
can start the video as well but that's
that's very cool yeah all right ah next
time without the technical difficulties
I'm sure yeah well sorry know if that's
that's all there is then thanks everyone
for your time we will we'll be back the
same time next week
this time i will put the moderator link
up sooner i'll try and i'll have it up
by the end of the day so you guys get a
more opportunity more of an opportunity
to send it out the other thing before we
go I just wanted to mention is that
today for the first time we used as the
Google+ events to organize the Hangout
let us know what you thought of that was
that useful did you know is that the the
way he prefers to work it was nice for
us to be able to see who was going to
join beforehand and so on so we're still
experimenting with this and we'd love to
hear what your experience is like our
car seems to be a huge fan so that's
good all right well with that being said
down will sign off for this week and we
will catch you same time next week thank
you goes by